[Musique]
les grands problèmes de l'heure ne sont
pas oubliés les eaux et les pigeons à
paris par exemple sont un problème il y
a trente pigeons bien sûr ils ont des
amis plein de sollicitude et fanta ce
qui fait partie du pittoresque locale
mais un regard il faut tenir compte des
dégâts qu'ils causent aux monuments
vénérable dont ils sont devenus la plaie
quotidienne sans parler des injures
causés aux gloires nationales
on conçoit que les édiles se soit
inquiété de leur dégradation et et tenté
déjà dans exils et quelques-uns mais ils
reviennent
ajoutez à cela que les gardiens du
patrimoine national ne sont pas ça la
vraie les pigeons de paris aux gémonies
les automobilistes aussi et les amoureux
alors alors il s'est trouvé deux
vilaines âmes pour faire plus que
souhaiter leur disparition
la précipiter quelques graines
empoisonnées ont ainsi provoqué l'agonie
d'innocents visait
méthode qui soulève l'indignation des
amis des bêtes alors il n'y pas tant
venise qui est-il lépi jeunes et les
sacrifie avec douceur c'est le terme
officiel limitera ton londres où l'on
daddy jeunes des bâtiments publics d'un
produit qui éloigne les oiseaux ou bien
vienne ou patiemment des spécialistes
vont stériliser les oeufs dans les nids
la décision en tout cas devient urgente
sinon on peut augurer que les ennemis
des pigeons vont passer à l'action
les uns mettant le bricolage et la
patience au service du noël longtemps
contenue les autres peut-être employant
les grands moyens et il est des
évocations tellement tories
[Musique]